[Music]
the first person she told she was
expecting was her wardrobe stylist on
her TV show younger me too
that makes a lot of food they knew it
because nothing would fit something too
well there is a reason why everybody's
talking about the fashion on this show
it was the vision of Sex in the City
creator Darren star and as I found out
for the show's leading ladies Hilary and
Sutton Foster it's like living in their
own wardrobe wonderland in younger
Sutton plays a 40-something mom
pretending to be a millennial in her 20s
to keep her job in publishing just so
you know sliding into the ences kind of
40 Hilary is her BFF and these ladies
have killer closets rocking labels like
Roland Maury Marc Jacobs and Gucci we're
filming on the street constantly looking
at each other and our salt our shoes
like walking around in New York in like
but the show's boldest fashion choices
come from their boss Diana trout played
by Miriam shor hate wearing pink it's
like Barbie's dream funeral and for
costume designer Jacqueline de material
finding Diana statement necklaces can be
a challenge things have just really
grown and grown and you know gotten
bigger and much more interesting for me
to find it is a huge fan favorite during
an episode characters can wear up to
eight different outfits and sometimes
the cast can't help but covet the
designer duds last season two I got the
most gorgeous Valentino bag you know
think I just gotta borrow it and then
I'm gonna bring it back and I brought it
back and I used it this season yeah we
did a photo shoot out on Coney Island
and I fell madly in love with this with
this jacket it ended up making its way
into my dressing room so that it could
go home with me well I think I took a
bra home that doesn't count underwear I
woke up in my Spanx
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]